now i would like to welcome dr sona
vasudevan dr sona vasudevan in trusts
spans the areas of structural biology
structural bioinformatics homology
modeling protein ligand and antibody
antigen interactions in rna biology her
research interests include comparative
genomics protein classification protein
homology modeling and molecular dynamics
simulation to look at the effect of
single nucleotide polymorphisms in
breast cancer evolutionary analysis
systems biology and translational
informatics dr sona vasudevan would be
talking about the systems medicine
education at georgetown uh
university over to you dr sona
thank you sonalika for that wonderful
introduction um
uh thank you uh elia for the um amazing
opportunity to be part of this um
symposium i've enjoyed it very
thoroughly so uh good morning good
afternoon good evening good night i know
there are lots of participants from
different parts of this world
um so i'm just going to spend the next
15-20 minutes to tell you about
let me share my screen
okay i hope you can see my slides here
yes ma'am we can see your screen thank
you
yes so i'm going to spend the next 15-20
minutes to tell you about an educational
program
that we have developed at georgetown
university which is masters in systems
medicine
um of course before i dwell into the
details of the program i want to let you
all know those of you have not visited
washington dc
uh you're welcome to visit because it's
actually a very beautiful place out here
um
especially especially during the spring
and justin university of course has
expert faculty
and a beautiful environment uh as well
so before i dwell into
the program itself
i i'm not sure how many of you have
heard of the term systems medicine uh
because this is a very new term
uh but i think it's becoming uh more and
more uh secondhand to those surfers who
actually
um practice informatics
so for those of you who are not heard of
this i just want to give you a brief
definition of what systems medicine is
this is a very
traditional definition developed by the
european systems medicine association so
it's a novel approach to medicine it is
the first step on the path to
personalized medicine
it's based on computer models in which
vast amounts of clinical data and the
end are used to analyze
health of individuals
and patients
it promises um to further our
understanding of disease mechanisms to
boost efficacy of treatments
and of course uh cut costs of health
care
um so
in a nutshell what systems medicine
means is it's one aspect of personalized
medicine
um and we know that even with cobit
we're all experiencing there's no two
individuals exhibit the same symptoms
we have a wide variety of symptoms
affecting wide variety of age groups
um and a wide variety of outcomes
so
you know this is the practical
definition of systems medicine
it is a
multi-disciplinary field that looks at
an individual as a whole
it uses systems biology and
computational sciences genomics
technologies to help solve bio
biomedical problems
and it is the future of medicine and i'm
sure you all will agree with me with the
explosion of data out there uh there is
no uh going away from looking at data
and putting things together we had lots
of interesting talks yesterday in the
symposium about different integration
techniques of all of this omit data and
and what the dire need for educating
informaticians and dr patnagar at amity
just uh
talked about amazing programs
to expand this field of informatics and
that is extremely welcome
so in summary what systems medicine is
all about
is
the realization
that one size does not fit all
two patients with the same symptoms same
findings
same disease
are given the same drug
but each patient exhibits different
outcomes
different reactions to these drugs
and why does this happen why does drug
response vary
this is what gives us the dimension
multi-dimensional problem to solve which
is at hand right now
so it all boils down to individual
variations between
two different
individuals individual patients
and these individual variations
stem from genetic differences between
individuals it could be as simple as one
single nucleated polymorphism
i don't have to emphasize to this
audience that majority of the diseases
that we see is actually caused by single
nucleotide changes sickle cell anemia is
just one single mutation
and we're talking about a lot of
variants right now so it's all um single
nucleated variations so there are lots
of variations that exist among human
population
and there is ethnicity differences age
genetic factors diseases drug drug
interactions
environment
nutrition so these are all some of the
major factors
that lead to different drug responses
among the different individuals
and why are we talking about this right
now um i don't have to again emphasize
to this audience audience
so at the mids we are at the midst of an
era of big biologic biological data and
we so happen to be in the middle of the
pandemic as well
and a revolution in medical practice is
happening as we speak with all of this
data coming from different atomic
technologies
so it all started here with the human
genome project um more than two decades
ago
it would
successfully we were able to map the
total number of human genes sequenced
human genes of course we are still
continuing to sequence the human genome
to get the most accurate picture of it
but today we stand here knowing that
we have
the number of total number of genes in
the human system is about twenty
thousand to twenty one thousand
um so this is actually this initiated a
whole cascade of different
avenues to pursue
and of course when the good news about
the human genome sequencing project was
completed
all of us including myself celebrated
thinking that this is the beginning of
end of a cure for all diseases but here
we stand after two decades we are still
not there yet we have made lots of
progress but we are still not there yet
because of the complexity that exists
in the human human genome itself
of course omics space all of you are
familiar with lots and lots of different
omics um that is and we are in the metal
phenomic era so ohmic space is actually
the pillar of systems medicine
so we have lots of different
layers of
genomics transcriptomics proteomics you
name it
and genomics is being used to integrate
pathways made into genes drug drug
interactions for various diseases
to add to all of this complexity
we are now dealing with another omics
which is the microbiome
uh with all of these individual
organisms that we all carry alongside
with our alongside our human genome and
human cells as well so these are all the
different omics where we have
a huge amount of data coming out of all
of this
and now the challenge that faces us is
how do we
look at and integrate all of this and
come up with an understanding of
diseases and understanding of human
biology
so genomics has become an universal
diagnostic tool in in clinics right now
and to understand the molecular
mechanisms of diseases i can't even
think any other way of looking at a
disease right now
uh even when i did my phd about two
decades ago
all we did was study one gene one
protein and the implication of
one gene and the mutations in it in a
disease
but here we can't do that anymore
because we have come to an understanding
that diseases are defined orthoplex of
course i'm not going to be the monogenic
diseases majority of the diseases are
more complex than that
so this has led us to look at genomics
and now we are currently using that as a
diagnostic too
too
um so systems medicine is already in
clinics and it's surfacing in various
different ways
big data using large datasets to learn
about gender population clinical
decisions and all of those things
of course reproductive endocrinology
testing embryos so potentially fatal
conditions we are we are here doing all
of this today
um genetic testing is available widely
um and we are able to uh catch a lot of
metabolic disorders in newborns
and tumor profiling music genetics to
taylor cancer treatments by tracking
mutations and pharmacogenomics assessing
individuals perspective related reaction
to a drug based on their genetic
specific makeup so we are already seeing
systems medicine in a day-to-day
practice of what we are doing
and here i stand today to let you know
that the other cell revolution in
medical practice
and and we are all about
efforts about disease prevention and
promoting health
that is our goal
so all of this data and all of this has
made us realize
that we are learning a new language
and it has led us to realize that we
actually need new educational programs
to learn this new new language
and this uh this education in my opinion
has to start from
schools high schools or undergrads
um and so georgetown university we
realized this
about a decade ago
and also of course all of you will agree
an investment in knowledge base the best
interest right so
so
that led us to create
a dual master's degree program in
systems medicine at georgetown
university
this was launched in 2011.
and the program of course i'm not going
to go in depth about the curriculum
itself um there may not be much time but
i'm happy to talk about it and send you
some links that um and you could go and
look at the details of the curriculum
the curriculum for this master's program
mainly was intended for students in
medical school who are completed years
of medical curriculum because these are
physicians that are going to be using
this data through treating you and me
so this program was intended to intended
to generate a new type of physician
one with the grasp of modern
computational sciences and opic
technologies genomics proteomics
methodology and translational sciences
etc so that they can embrace this into
their practice of medicine
when they are looking at that and of
course more importantly to understand
the systems approach to medicine ah
because one size as i mentioned one size
does not fit all and it is not about one
chain one protein ah it is about a whole
systems that actually we have to look at
in order to understand a disease
so uh after a successful launch of a
dual degree program
we came to the realization that this
language has to be taught to all
students no matter what the career paths
might be
so that led us to create another
master's program
which is a freestanding master's program
in 2016 and it was intended for any
student
who's interested in
understanding biomedical
any discipline in my biomedical sciences
this is a generate this is again to
generate a new type of scientist new
type of physician new type of
any healthcare individual who can also
learn this language to embrace that we
can so again more importantly to
understand persistence approach to
medicine and research
so we launched those two programs and
i'm not going to go deep into the
curriculum itself but just to
give you a flavor
um students have to complete 30 degree
30 credits of gross requirements
that includes core courses that each
student is actually trained in that
include biostatistics
biomedical informatics
journal
critically reading scientific literature
which is becoming actually very very
important unless you understand how to
read a scientific paper we're not going
to be able to understand what is out
there and to critically review different
techniques and technologies to make
amends and improvements to all of those
and to be able to understand how to
analyze clinical patient data that's out
there we have huge amount of
data that's available
in different resources
and of course as i mentioned microbiome
is becoming extremely important and how
what are the different organisms that
are up and down regulated in different
situations what is a normal
microbiota so we have courses that teach
the students how to look at microbiome
and it what are the different aspects to
genomics and how do you take
data from bench to bedside and how do
you translate all of the data
and the experimental data that is out
there and
looking at metabolomics
with everything is about metabolomics
any reaction in our body is going to
give you metabolites so so this is the
um
a picture of the courses that students
actually learn
and of course in addition to the courses
students actually end up taking elective
courses based on their interests and
based on their career paths so we have
several different courses that span from
looking at drug design three-dimensional
structures
to looking at how do you think in
systems right and also how we create
policies and how do you look at all of
this ah in a lab and how do you learn
all of this so this is
of course the details of all of these
courses you can find it on our website
and students are allowed to take courses
across
the entire
different departments at georgetown they
can learn about epidemiology or they can
learn about diets they can learn about
supplements and all of those things
the most important part of the
curriculum is a capstone project so
students are mandated to do
a good portion of their time they spend
doing research so you can learn as much
as you want in a class setting listening
to lectures but unless you know how to
uh learn how you learn to apply these in
a research setting uh it's not going to
be a practical use
and we will be educating these students
to use of those all of these different
uh techniques and resources and tools
that they learn in a class setting so
capstone is a very integral part of the
program and students spend more than 240
hours doing research and the research
culminates in a poster presentation and
majority of the students end up
publishing being part of a publication
um so which as
they learn how to write a paper they
publish a paper and
they know how to apply
all of the tools that they learn so
research is an integral part of the
program
and students have variety of options to
go and do their mental internships we
have several mentors this is just only a
flavor of the institutions in and around
georgetown where students actually
go and do
uh their mentoring of course in addition
to all of this students um have mentors
in industry and other university uh
universities as well so we have a wide
network of collaborations
across different universities and
industry
settings
so the question is
what are the skill sets that these
students
actually get out of this program and if
you are out there looking to hire these
are all the skill sets that they get so
they understand
what is big data so what it means to
actually deal with humongous amount of
data so they also understand what
sequencing means they understand how to
carry out next in sequence analysis rna
seq analysis microbiome data analysis so
they are exposed to how to do
use the data and meaningfully extract
knowledge from these data
we also teach by chemistry which i think
is fundamental whether you're a
researcher or whether you are a
physician or anything you i have to
understand by chemistry but the way we
teach biochemistry is based on cases
uh it is about patients cases so they
understand that a patient walks into the
clinic
has these symptoms and they understand
how to troubleshoot to figure out which
gene
is going how we can then what mutations
they have which pathways is implicated
so that they have an understanding of
the disease from a systems perspective
and thanks to pine biotech and ilia we
have been able to launch a course on
machine learning
uh and ai and uh i'm very excited about
this so students learn um machine
learning as well aspects and they also
learn about um health care
in terms of electronic health records
electronic medical records how do you
mine them how do you get value
uh how do you take
basic research tube from bench to that
side um and they also of course learn
learn how to read an article scientific
scientific article which is actually
very very important for you to be able
to distinguish between
good papers and critically thinking um
and analyzing the results of a
publication they also learn how to mine
patient data how they use inflation data
how do you understand uh the forms of
all of these patient error last but not
the least they also
um learn to get their hands a little bit
wet to understand how do you generate
good dna or rna that can be sent for
sequencing and what are the caveats in
there so how do you understand between
good data good sequencing data and bad
sequencing data so we use we expose them
to the nano core sequencer so uh they
learn how to actually hold the sequencer
into the sequencing so these are all
um the skill sets that the students
actually learn
from the program
and there is something for everyone
so those students who actually come to
us for the mpms
program they of course go and become
physicians um and those students who
actually do the ms program go to go on
to go to medical school nursing school
be a orto schools or um go into phd
programs or work in industries academic
settings and of course health and
doctors offices so there is something
for everyone in the program so we are
all about skill sets and so they develop
lots of skill sets that they can apply
in different industries and different
job settings um so the question that's
always asked us where are the graduates
now so the graduates are all over the
place here some of them have are in
medical schools phd programs nursing
schools um and of course several of them
are working at several different
universities um nih fda and all of those
so um so the students get placed pretty
well
and uh of course why georgetown and i'm
proud to say that the program is the
first in the nation and of course we
have outstanding faculty and we have an
outstanding team um to help us uh of
course it all boils down to whether we
have scholarships that we support the
students yes we do have several
different scholarships that students can
apply to
um so we have an endowment of hundred
thousand dollars that was generously
provided by robert stephen lightly um um
enjoyment scholarships and we also have
lots of different biomedical graduate
scholarships of course all of the
details are um okay you can find it in
the website and i'll post the link to
our website in a second
of course it's not all about academics
students have a very good life
we go out for lunches we party we
celebrate different things
and we have a social life as well and
there's a wonderful academic life as
well students at conferences they
present their work
they they are taking field trips to the
nih uh do they see the sequencing
facilities and you can see all of them
are smiling so the program does treat
them well
um and so they do have in addition to
their academic life they do have a good
social life as well um so this is the
website to the program if you want to
learn more
um and i just want to actually leave a
few minutes for
questions so that i can elaborate on
anything else that you may need
from this and i want to thank you for
your attention and if i'm happy to take
any questions you may have
okay thank you very much uh dr vasudevan
we do have a question
uh do you have an opinion on the
advancement of alpha fold that will
change the scene and structure biology
field in the near future
that's actually an outstanding question
uh i am a structural biologist but i am
a structural biologist by training
myself and uh yes it is going to
uh completely revolutionize the way we
are going to do structural biology
and as you know that um already you know
people are using um ai and machine
learning and in fact we have a
structural biology team at georgetown
university who are actually used to the
concepts to come up with uh some
you know therapeutics for cobit 19.
and the answer is yes i've been waiting
for this and the answer is yes this is
going to
move the field
very fast
so that we'll be able to design drugs uh
in a much more systematic manner as well
what we could not do before we're able
to do because we don't have to depend on
the experimental sciences uh but of
course there are lots of caveats too we
are not there yet but we are getting
there and i think this is definitely
going to revolutionize um i'm very
excited i'm actually
learning and using it myself
so the answer is yes
okay thank you very much so in your
opinion how do you see someone with the
master's degree in molecular biology and
genetics fit into systems medicine
oh um actually
i would definitely welcome in fact i
would love to have students who have the
background in biology and genetics to be
able to contribute to informatics as you
know informatics is actually an
application field we do depend on
experimental biologists and the
knowledge from experimental biologists
to make sense of all of this data that
is coming out and in fact
most of my students who come actually i
i require that they have a biology
background and if you have a molecular
biology background and genetics
that's an added it'll be an asset to
have such expertise in the program
uh and you will actually gain much more
uh than just um
a person uh without a little bit of
biology background
and so the final question is two-part
question so do you have any
international students that join your
program
and if somebody like that wants to apply
uh how are they going to
handle the registration and fees it
seems like the program is very expensive
well this is actually some of my heart
bleeds because i do want a lot of
international students and what limits
is the expense yes i the answer the
first part of the question the answer is
yes i do have
um international students um i have
graduated almost about seven or eight
international students
um in the program since its inception in
2016. um and i know that expense is a
big a big problem and i'm trying to find
funds uh there are merit paid
scholarships that the program uh
provides um and if you have a
merit-based uh if you are you qualify
for that you definitely of course it's
not a lot of money so that is something
that i'm actively pursuing to figure out
how to generate revenue so that i can
um create more scholarships for
international students um so we do have
a lot of international students actually
judged on and and personally i do in
fact i have a couple of international
students who are going to be starting
tomorrow
for this fall